at 42 years old started realizing I can  communicate with the universe you know  the geometry has been all around us all  the time but if you don't stop if you  just get stuck in your day-to-day  routine of life you can easily miss all  of these things  but fundamentally I believe that we're  here to find and remember these things  in addition to learning how to transcend  judgment and learning to love and  replace judgment with acceptance and  replace fear with gratitude then you  start to learn how to to non-judge and  to observe rather than judge and try to  look at different perspectives maybe the  way I'm seeing it is not the only way to  see it and that's when your mind really  expands and then the next step after  that is to realize that maybe the  universe is actually speaking to me  maybe there is some form of Destiny  maybe I chose it  maybe this is a game I'm living